have this problem and this isn't this
isn't a you thing it's just like a thing
I hate it when people come on and tell
me how to talk on my podcast it's like
if you were so good at it then you would
do it and you would make it bigger and
so it's like how are you gonna go to
them and say oh I know how to talk
it's just me yeah you know I'm talking
about in this example for fresh and fit
yeah because I've been in this situation
I've been in this situation where like a
girl will say I don't like the way you
like they'll be like oh I don't like the
way she does this I don't like this I
don't know what like whatever it is and
my my first thought is like how
delusional are you if you could do it
better you would